in this video I want to talk a little
bit about a comparison of prokaryotes
and eukaryotes in transcription in terms
of their promoter regions and their
transcription machinery which is
basically just their RNA polymerases so
in prokaryotes their promoter regions
have three specific thematic regions
those regions are the negative 35 region
the negative 10 region which actually
has a specific name it's called the
Pribnow box and the third region is the
plus 1 region which is the transcription
start site now the eukaryotic promoters
are a little bit different they have
really sort of one primary thematic
region and that is the tata box which is
a region filled with t's and a's and
it's actually between the negative 36
and negative 24 regions these negative
numbers imply that they're more upstream
positive number implies that it's
downstream you'll notice I put stars by
these the Y the tata box in the negative
10 region with the protein a box and the
reason why is because those are very 8e
rich regions but they have a lot of a's
and t's and that's actually sort of
uniform among all sorts of genes and
that makes sense because you would
expect that promoter to have a sort of
theme that the RNA polymerase can
continually be attracted to because
these promoters keep like I mentioned in
the other video the RNA polymerase has a
high affinity for them and again the
reason for that is because the promoter
regions determine where transcription
starts and so RNA polymerase needs to go
there it needs to go to the promoter or
at least somewhere in its vicinity so
now let's talk about the transcription
machinery of each of these the
prokaryotes and eukaryotes
when I say transcription machinery I'm
really just talking about
RNA polymerase the enzyme that actually
makes the RNA so in prokaryotes they
really only have one RNA polymerase they
have one RNA polymerase eukaryotes they
have three okay let's focus on the
prokaryotes first prokaryotic this thing
called the core enzyme which consists of
a few different subunits those subunits
are two alpha subunits a an Omega
subunit a beta unit and a beta prime
unit these unity subunits make up the
core enzyme and the core enzyme of the
RNA polymerase is constant which means
that anytime RNA polymerase or it is
going to work or anytime there is a
specific sequence that needs to be
transcribed all of these subunits will
be there all the time for sure
now this core enzyme is added to this
Sigma subunit now this Sigma subunit is
variable and I'll talk a little bit more
about it in just a moment but together
if you put this core enzyme with all
these subunits with a specific variable
Sigma subunit what you get is this thing
called a holoenzyme and so that's
basically just the core enzyme and all
of its subunits with the sigma sub unit
attached now the Sigma subunit is
variable so now what is the Sigma
subunit there are a bunch of different
Sigma subunits okay now these Sigma
subunits what they they are dependent
upon the gene being transcribed you'll
have maybe this Sigma subunit number one
for this gene and Sigma sub unit number
387 for this other gene I'm not really
exactly too sure about that but I know
that the different Sigma subunits are
used for different genes it depends on
the gene being transcribed so what is
the purpose then of the Sigma subunit
but it does is it aids in binding the
gene and then it
aidan starting transcription off so it
aids in binding the genius starting
transcription this core enzyme needs a
little bit of help and he's a little bit
of assistance from a sigma sub unit in
order to bind the promoter region before
it gets started with transcription so
once a few nucleotides are added the
Sigma subunit hops off it leaves and
what's left is the core enzyme so the
core enzyme will then continue
polymerizing until termination so the
core enzyme and the Sigma subunit make
up the holo enzyme that whole thing is
called the RNA polymerase now in
eukaryotes is a little bit different
they don't have just one core enzyme and
then variable Sigma subunits what they
have is three different RNA polymerases
collaborative named RNA polymerase one
two and three now RNA polymerase one two
and three each has their own job so I
remember this in a simple way and
because I mean that this is what's gonna
help me most I think are M T like maybe
that's a little bit small R M T one two
three so our RNA is synthesized by RNA
polymerase one that's what RNA
polymerase is one JIT RNA polymerase is
one it's job is to synthesize our RNA
for the most part it synthesizes most of
the our RNA in a Cell RNA polymerase 2
makes mRNA RNA polymerase 3 makes tRNA
it also makes some our RNA which is why
I wrote most up here but generally
speaking our M T one two three that's
what helps you remember this in addition
to the RNA polymerase is eukaryotes also
have these things called transcription
factors now transcription factors are
little happy helpers if you will when it
comes to transcription
they are proteins that aid in
transcription that's pretty much a sort
of general idea of what they are so they
can be a transcription factor one
transcription factor two transcription
factor three depending on the RNA
polymerase that they're helping out so
if you know the type of RNA being
synthesized then you know the type of
RNA polymerase and if you know the RNA
polymerase you should know the traps
transcription factors associated with it
if it's transcription by the number one
it'll be helping out RNA polymerase one
two for RNA polymerase 2 3 4 our and a
point three so I wrote this little blank
here and I'm kind of just going to write
an X here because normally these
transcription factors are named with a
certain letter for instance an example
would be transcription factor 2d which
we'll talk a little bit more about we're
talking about mRNA transcription in
eukaryotes so that about wraps it up as
far as the comparison between
prokaryotes and eukaryotes and their
promoter regions and their transcription
machinery I hope that video was helpful
one last thing I am a tutor if you live
in Southern California feel free to
contact me via email at move University
at gmail.com and see the description
below for more details thank you for
watching